à les marier au premier regard c'est le
focus de l'été ils soient qui fonctionne
très très bien sur m6 surtout sur les
cimes commercialement sur un maxi
meilleure saison historique sur cette
nouvelle saison auprès notamment des
femmes responsables des achats de moins
de 50 ans 32% ces normes rendre de 11 2%
ah ben là je vois 2 millions 900 mille
en moyenne sur cette saison et 15% du
public qui regarde chariot alors on
rappelle le concept ce sont des gens qui
ne se connaissent pas qu'ils ont eue
contenu compatibilité parait-il un peu
scientifique scientifique voilà et qui
vont son oncle donc s'épouser au premier
regard petit récap
cette saison de mario premier regard sur
m6 nous a permis découvrir pleins
nouveaux candidats comme anthony qui
avait des critères bien à lui le fils ou
manchester numéro un génie les fesses
forcément n'en est pas une car de façon
plus voilà non plus donc mais quand même
cindy était ravie d'annoncer son père
qu'elle avait enfin trouvé la mort alors
je suis compatible avec un homme à 76%
allez encore 24 heures même d'ailleurs
qui très bien
et dix ans notre candidat est arrivé à
son mariage un peu aux stress on n'est
pas sûr que l'enchaînement des questions
des invités les aider à aller mieux que
tu t'appelles comment tu as quel âge tu
as des enfants te fait quoi dans la vie
frédéric avaient trait de danser avec sa
chérie à son mariage
c'est bien un shérif parce que moi aussi
j'attends j'attends plus de sens et on a
assez vite compris pourquoi
[Musique]
et de quoi rendre son beau-père bien
vénère
et 10 attentes et préparer sa femme ann
hui nos stories reste à voir si ça brise
qui va être très bizarre c'est que j'ai
l'habitude de dormir à 126 en sous
vêtements noirs m'a fait flipper et
enfin pauline et son nouveau mari était
visiblement très pressé de consommer
leur mariage et sur notre petit nuage je
pense parcours à redescendre ce soir tu
aimerais que c'était un peu tout et
mousse tôt fait prête un annulaire on
verra ce qui va se passer mais je pense
qu'il ya des choses qui vont se passer
assez naturel c'est costaud on a compris
dès le premier regard donc ces gros
succès cette année alors contrer ce cas
je sais que vous adorez démission non
mais sérieux non mais j'ai vraiment du
mal mais halluciné par les chiffres que
tu me sors mais il faut que je parle aux
gens et pourquoi en fait pour que vous
rigolez non mais parce que sérieusement
l'amour c'est quoi c'est de vivre
ensemble c'est le contact c'est de se
connaître c'est d'apprendre à savoir si
ses 20 ans mais ce qu'il fait rire ce ce
qu'il a au début c'est non mais savait
pas dire non
mais tu vois bien ce que je veux dire
fin du mois avec ton petit tableau mais
est-ce qui vous dérapez taboulé on
apprend que tu voudrais blanche et on va
conduire c'est de la télé réalité oui
mais sans doute foutage de gueule parce
qu'on pitt sur l'institution inventerait
du mariage et qu'elle beaucoup de gens
qui respectent le mariage le mariage
c'est aussi une institution religieuse
et je suis désolé alors ça veut dire
mais je m'en fous je m'en fous ça fait
aussi partie du mariage je veux dire on
unit de personnes est en fait en gros on
aurait là football basile l'on mêle la
famille pratique géré vite on tombe à
6,1 dit maman va-t-il jouer les enfants
mais également dans l'histoire des
enfants mon histoire comment tu peux
m'aider tes enfants comme ça une parodie
pas moi ça me rend mais à chaque fois
qu'on reparle de ces maisons ça mais
dans le même état et je comprends
mais toi tu as les et pourquoi bd ni
deux mais moi je suis un peu c'est
triste à dire mais je savais qu'on
rigole pas trop sauvage là tu as
l'impression que c'est une loterie
fabien chiffre qui sort en effet la leur
lorsque je voyais haut débit moyen se
marier l'année prochaine mais c'est que
le mariage ça se pousse sahraouis faut
du nord marie regarde benjamin il va il
va nous en parler idées naidan a fait
quatre mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que mais non mais il faut prendre
le temps voilà c'est juste moi j'ai mon
mec quand vous êtes bérenguier après si
ça devient mondial u sur une latrine z
etc les gens sont heureux mais je varie
9 chances sur 10 rbds s'apprête à chaque
fois alors janvier où le niveau 10
c'est la meilleure émission de bennis
250 franchement depuis la télé couleur
il ya pas une meilleure émission
à
cette exception moi j'attends de la
télévision qu'elle me surprennent pas
gonzague avec ce genre de concept moi je
parle pas du mariage le paria je le
respecte évidemment ça je parle de l'
objet télévisuel ewing les gens boys
après participe même pas c'est leur
problème mais moi je compte je regarde
ça en tant qu'ennemi son divertissement
et sa concept original t'as vu nulle
part ailleurs là tu es surpris ton plein
les yeux il ya de l'émotion tu as des
déceptions tu te fous doit toutefois un
peu d'eux et c'est
parce que là on va voir un petit extrait
qui concerne la fameuse robe de mariée
moment important s'il en est regardez
weather
oui c'est trop beau aux à tort
le nouveau
vos lumières veilleux
j'adore parce que c'est ma c'est moi
vous en pensez quoi
ça veut
pour moi non
ça doit non mais moi je préfère dans une
robe
messieurs ben moi je
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour moi ccpo normes de
mariée est coincé
c'est pas un événement bien particulier
mais pas un peu de mariée hqe au
décollage je sais vous allez me disent
bravo je me mets du côté public et c'est
une émission car j'aime regarder il ya
du rebond est très jolie histoire il ya
des gens qui se rencontrent et qui
attendent des semaines et des semaines
avant de faire un rapprochement il ya du
respect moi c'est une émission pour le
coup l'attend un peu d'audace de la
télévision je trouve que cette émission
est audacieuse et respectueuse je trouve
pas qu'ils aient de second degré ou des
trucs un peu mal au coeur c'est vrai je
trouve qu'il ya un vrai justement il ya
un
vrai on aime ça attendez on aime on
n'aime pas le concept après on se met
côté de téléspectateurs c'est moi mais
c'est une émission que je regardais que
je suis déçu en bas et que j'aime la
télé bien la manière je voudrais vous
faire un avc message coach local des
chiffres là qui a pas de message bien
les chiffres et les lettres a pas de
message mais bon tu as
vu mon droit français non non non non
qu'ils aient gêné par la remise en cause
de l'institution mariage attendent
excusez-moi la remise en cause ainsi
sion francesca franchement c'est hyper
personnel en fait parce que toi tu as
une vision du mariage qui est comme ça
mais il ya d'autres personnes qui ont
une vision du mariage différentes les
emprunts d'états d'âme on fait jouer
81 % des gens restent ensemble il ya
même des enfants qui sont les années
certaines religions des fois tu as des
rencontres qui sont tout de suite par
exemple nous et chez la rue dans la
juste part donc tu fais ce qu'on appelle
un chiffre d'août met de la mission de
rencontres comme ça c'est en une fois et
ils se marient genre toute situation
s'est
lentement tout n'est pas parti oui alors
religieusement c'est une insulte comme
ça c'est une insulte comme ça parce que
c'est pas vrai c'est pour toi tu le vis
comme ça mais il ya d'autres personnes
qui aiment bien et qui ils sont heureux
comme ça tu as et comme son beau costume
la tana qui se mariera en robe de mariée
pour eux c'est sûr super symbolique
d'être en robe et put à cette fille là
qui rêve d'être en tailleur et qui sont
d'ailleurs le mariage c'est personnel
juste de se marier avec quelqu'un qui
t'aime quand même juste
ils sont compatibles
wi chimie tu prends les jimmy ou écouter
des bons jeux vous aimiez enfin pas à
vous mais j'aime bien 6,9 parce que
sachez que c'est le pourcentage de coupe
qui sont restés mariés depuis le début
de l'émission c'est ensuite la balle
plus que la vraie vie c'est couple il y
en a sept qui sont restés mariés quand
on met ça en émission et en plus ça fait
donc six états et les 69 16 ans 69 et
c'est plus que la première puisque vous
connaissez la vitesse limite en amour
estimée à
68 km parce qu'après on fait un
tête-à-queue tata que j'adore je valide
oui messieurs
non
mais cette année sont les experts qui
pour moi ce sont ces variations fait
l'enfant le bsca elle là on va regarder
cet extrait parce qu'on a quand même des
spécimens évidemment de ceux qui sont là
pour voir on sent qu'ils sont là pour ce
qu'arrivent les toits aussi ils veulent
vraiment kenna on a un couple travaille
très très très chaud là il a un beau
corps il a un corps qui me plaît et j'ai
hâte de découvrir encore plus
j'adore c'est fort ça me plaît ce que je
vois je vois moi j'ai petit bourg soeur
militaire je compte donner deux heures
moi je suis je suis très chaud c'est un
moment qu'on attendait à ce désir à fond
voilà
mais le mariage ça s'est super bien
passé on a vraiment fait la découverte
de la envers l'autre
ça endormi l'un dans l'autre
[Musique]
et à maxime guérie les plaies émission
elle a un avantage qui est aussi son
inconvénient c'est qu'elle est selon moi
trop feuilletonnante cette année j'ai
raté le train je vous le prendre en
marche j'ai pas réussi tu rates l
épisode tu rates toute la saison c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai mis un set
est-ce que ça reste efficace quoi qu'il
en soit
comme les feux de l'amour tu rentres
dedans tu comprends rien suivi d'un
temps avant il
[Musique]
n'y a pas grand chose à comprendre
qu'on s'aime quand même si ils ont même
pas tourné le mariage en france dans ses
salles gibraltar
vous voyez vous regardez l'émission par
exemple on a vu le vrai nuage de pauline
choix et à l'est d'amiens qui sont hyper
amoureux on a vu les parents se
retrouver tous ensemble autour des
enfants à prévoir mais moi je ris ya des
maths histoire-géo que j'étais un peu
comme francesca au début et finalement
je trouve que voilà ça a un côté positif
et je regarde surtout pour me marrer
parce que quand on voit ce qui se passe
au moment de la nuit de noce parce que
forcément ça ils ont mis en scène
généralement tous ceux qui sont comme ça
ils font reculer regarder
rentrée des jeux olympiques florent
manaudou a rejoint frédérick bousquet et
le reste de leur clan de nageurs pour
assister au mariage du dernier
célibataire de la bande on a la chance
d'avoir un groupe d'amis phr a je
travaille en événementiel sur l'île
j'essaie de cacher ma timidité je me
tiens allez et filage toile tout ce qui
est logistique services de sécurité
hôtesses d'ailleurs pourrait travailler
pour nous et habillés comme des hôtesses
moi ça c'est pas très gentil ça après
sa tête
je dis des bêtises désolé c'est juste
que vous êtes tous uniforme quoi
c'est pas méchant
à la fin j'étais les blagues un peu
gênante et là on va garder le moment de
la nuit de noces et c'est vrai que c'est
souvent ça nous fait marrer parce que on
va dire que deux fois sur trois il se
passe rien dans leur état normal normale
normale garder durant le côté gauche
tout côté droit je suis soulagé on dort
ensemble c'est cool je pense qu'avec
jennifer ça va très très bien se passer
mais je pense qu'on reste est partagé
need juste pas prête à l'heure vient
écrire
d'accord j'irai pas dans le canapé pour
ma propre fierté je vais marier
maintenant et e elle doit comprendre que
ma place est allée dans le lit conjugal
et pas dans un canapé enfin sociaux je
suis un set je peux pas dire grand chose
un mois donné
enfin trail pour toi
[Musique]
c'est là où c'est là où il faut qu'ils
aillent les medal émission parce que
voilà bah oui à des bonnes nouvelles le
gars est là il vient il la connaît
depuis deux heures et dix non alors elle
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est hélas un peu
pour la faille mais bon passons elle dit
non parce qu'elle ne connaît pas il est
live facebook et s'est qualifié pour la
finale à bercy il est très patient
puisqu'il l'attend des
compressions voiliers mais comment mais
dans le même temps monsieur 30 mais là
ça fait quelques semaines que ça y est
il ya eu pas mal d'épisodes oui c'est ça
ils sont plus attendues il lui a laissé
du temps ce qui est plutôt pas mal parce
que elle était sa marque et le parti
dans cette histoire
prenez soin à son arrivée alors ta
vérité si dans l'émission à chaque fois
à chaque fois qu'elle a d'une noce il
couché ensemble nous dit que c'est que
c'est ce qu'on a
mais non ça sert à ça non alors ça là
les hommes de la mine et de nogent
effets 4d ninos les maires la une de
bien enfin même radio n'a rien de
nouveau bien
puisqu'ils comme ça tu es complètement
bourré t1
alors shenzhen coucher alors c'est pour
moi la paix
globalement oui tu finis
et face au succès de marie au premier
regard m6 a développé un nouveau dating
qui à l'heure cette année ça s'appelle
gold foudre au bout du yoga vous avez
des curés ou dans les cinq continents
qui ont ouvert des fous du bout du monde
est allé jouer oui mais
voilà alors la moyenne de l'émission a
pas mal si juste derrière face à balai